hello everyone and welcome to part three
of our four part series on 3d culture
and analysis how to analyze characterize
your 3d culture I'm Christie Joe of lab
works and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific to learn more about
our sponsor please visit thermo Fisher
comm now let's get started you can pose
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind
to do so simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
send questions will be answered
following the presentation
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab sound at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Chris Lang
stores staff scientists Thermo Fisher
Scientific Chris's complete biography
can be found in the biography tab at the
top of your screen Chris you may now
begin your presentation
all right Thank You Christy for the
introduction and thanks to you and my
roots for hosting this webinar and also
thanks to everyone in the audience for
joining us as we discuss our research on
labeling and detection and 3d models
specifically with fluorescent reagents
so today we'll we'll break the webinar
into three sections first why are we
interested in analyzing
three-dimensional models as a transition
from two-dimensional second how we can
visualize and analyze these 3d models
specifically what instruments are
valuable for this and then third what
are the key assays and reagents we use
to label ourselves to analyze different
processes in these three-dimensional
cell models so first why are we
interested in three-dimensional models
so who typically will do fluorescence
microscopy on cells that exist in a
monolayer on a flat plastic dish but
increasingly we're seeing researchers
transition to a three-dimensional
spheroid model where we know that
growing cells in a model layer as we see
here in the quote that this is
fundamentally dissimilar from how cancer
cells exist in a 3-dimensional tumor
things like the growth rates
morphologies metabolism and the
interaction of cells with each other and
with their substrates are very different
in a two-dimensional versus
3-dimensional model now if we look at
this in more detail as far as different
considerations for these two different
culture systems we see that with 3d
models we expect a more natural cell
morphology and more representative
expression patterns of proteins also
critically the diffusion patterns of
drugs growth factors things in our
culture medium to our cells
vary across cells in a three-dimensional
system on the potential downside there
are things we need to optimize so our
experimental workflows
the assays that we're used to using need
some special tips and tricks to use
these appropriately in a
three-dimensional system and also we're
now dealing with an added level of
complexity that can add some technical
challenges so today we'll look at how we
can overcome these challenges and apply
some of our characteristic axes to these
three-dimensional models we expect in a
three-dimensional model to see a more
representative morphology that better
relates to an in vivo tumor where we can
see that the reproduction of
characteristic differences in cellular
activity on the left here we see a
difference in proliferative ring so we
can see in green as eliminated by our
sullivan caspase-3 7 green reagent we're
able to visualize the aquatic or
necrotic core of those cells that are
isolated from growth factors and oxygen
and become necrotic on the right we also
illustrate with our image at hypoxia
green reagent that the core of these
three-dimensional structures is present
in a reduced oxygen tension and so as
we'd expect there's a gradient of not
only oxygen but also metabolites and
nutrients across this 3-dimensional
structure so this has implications for
not only how we label ourselves but also
what what biology is occurring in cells
depending on where they exist throughout
this structure now when it comes to
actually imaging through this
3-dimensional structure we can use a
wide field imaging in which the InFocus
image from our plane of cells of
interest is mixed with the out-of-focus
light from regions outside the focal
plane and so we see essentially a
blurred image here
however with laser scanning confocal
microscopy also to image just a thin
slice out of this thick set thick
specimen and
reject light from other planes that are
not in our desired focal plane so we
have better resolution that sells deep
within this three-dimensional structure
so we'll look in more detail at
instruments that provide this capability
of imaging into larger structures
and so here's an example using actual
fluorescence where we can visualize live
and dead cells both with wide field and
confocal imaging and it's clear that the
cells on the interior of this
3-dimensional structure are visible at
greater resolution when we're using
confocal imaging so today we'll look at
not just the instruments that we use to
image and analyze three-dimensional
cells but also how we can use a range of
different fluorescent reagents of course
and fluorescence based assays to label
these structures to provide insight into
the biology we're studying and so first
we'll look at the instruments that we
can use to visualize and analyze these
three-dimensional models and how we can
use these in optimal experiments to
characterize our 3d structures so first
when it's time to form our 3-dimensional
spheroid in this case it's critical that
we have control over the number of cells
that are being used to grow a particular
spheroid so using an instrument called
the mutagen countess - automated cell
counter we can very quickly using 10
microliters of our cells obtain an
accurate measurement of concentration
and viability so that we can see the
correct number of cells and a consistent
number of cells per well in our 96-well
plate - row spheroids of a consistent
and controlled size now when it's time
to grow our spheroids we recommend a
plate called the noncoms fira 96-well
plate to grow consistent spheroid x'
with a homogeneous spherical shape two
ways we see here on the bottom right as
we increase the number of cells per well
we see a larger spheroid structure as we
expect
now using a similar plate that's not
treated as the non con spirit is we see
occasionally non-ideal
formation of C roids so two things that
are critical
counting ourselves and then using an
appropriate plastic where to grow a nice
round spheroid so now when it's time to
image these and evaluate the biology
occurring inside these three-dimensional
structures of fluorescence is really
ideal because it provides us a way to
not only label ourselves and distributed
I throughout the structure to report
different functions but to detect light
given off by that sensor and so with
fluorescence were able to maintain the
three-dimensional structure and the
interactions between cells in this
structure and using different probes we
can measure the abundance or also the
localization within the structure of
different proteins or different
processing your functions that are
occurring within its sphere oeid so we
look at several examples of those when
it's time to look at assays and reagents
so for visualizing and analyzing our 3d
models we look at three different
instruments where as we see in the first
quote here visualization is fundamental
to document the differentiation on a
daily basis and our second quote that
this can be a time-consuming process to
grow a three dimensional structure we
need a robust imaging system to be sure
that the things are going correctly
during this process so we'll look at
three things the evos imaging systems
our high content analysis platforms and
then also the Vario scan line of plate
readers for whole cell or our whole well
analysis
so first the evos M 7000 instrument is a
wide field microscope that's fully
automated with high-speed acquisition so
that you can scan multiple wells 96
wells if you like but also with the
power to create Z stacks or image of
wide area
dial or stitch those images into one
large reconstructed image it's also
compatible with an on-stage incubator so
you can control not only the temperature
but gasses and humidity on your cells to
perform time-lapse live cell imaging and
finally once we've acquired our images
we can do a 3d image analysis with the
in vitro j'en image celeste image
analysis software so one example of how
we use celeste is to essentially create
a mask around our entire spheroid we see
here in red the red circle we've
identified our spheroid and the yellow
circle we've identified our background
for one spheroid and we can apply this
mask to every image in our experiment
and quantify the fluorescence in our
different markers that we have applied
and so in this case we see a 96-well
plate pull up in this case a five for
nine lung cancer steroids where we can
image every single one of those and not
only have the qualitative information of
the image but we can extract
quantitative information so first on the
top right we can look at the size of the
spheroid and we see after a drug
treatment that the size the average size
or average area of every spheroid has
decreased after treatment and also in
the bottom panel we see our treatment
increases the level of a green signal
reporting caspase-3 and seven activity
and so we see our treatment
significantly increases the signal of
caspase reporting apoptosis
so we can perform this kind of analysis
on the eBoost microscope another system
that's valuable for this kind of high
content analysis is the cell insight
cx-7 laser high content analysis
platform and so from this we can provide
the same image based quantitative
cellular data so the cx-7 laser has a
seven channel laser based illumination
also with a powerful HCS Studio software
to analyze your images and so we can
collect data on per cell basis and
multiplex with several different markers
this instrument is also live cell
compatible and so we can use the same
Evo's on stage incubator to control the
environment inside the instrument to
keep ourselves happy and growing for
kinetic experiments or longer-term
experiments now with high content
analysis we have a slightly more
sophisticated software which provides an
automated acquisition and analysis that
helps us improve and speed up our data
capture and our downstream analysis so
essentially what we do is label
ourselves with something in this case
label our entire spheroid with the
dialect host 3 through 34 - this will
provide a landmark on on each individual
cell so that we can distinguish and put
a software-based mask on each individual
so then we can apply it a second or
third probe in this case we'll use a TM
RM and we see the image in this channel
and I'll ask the software to create a
mask identify not only each cell based
on their nuclear thing but also to
identify the amount or the brightness of
signal in our second channel and so by
doing so we'll provide a cell by cell
measurement of our mitochondrial
membrane potential I
this very large three-dimensional
structure now that we have this
information we can plot it not as an
image but as a fluorescence based
histogram and see the average of the
mean intensity on a per cell basis of
this probe
so now we can extrapolate this and look
at our entire spheroid and get an
average intensity of in this case might
attract their orange or cell tracker
green across the entire spheroid so a
cell by cell quantitative analysis
extracted from a single image so in
addition to the quantitative analysis we
can perform stitching on this instrument
as well so we have a larger structure to
image we can take a large number of
different images in this case with four
different colors and merge not only the
four different colors together but merge
all of the single images together to
provide a very large and high-resolution
image of this large structure that we
want to image so moving on to a third
way to analyze our 3d structures here
we'll look at a microplate reader called
the Vario scan Lux this is a multimode
plate reader that is very versatile
giving us up to five different types of
measurements this could be absorbance
this could be fluorescence luminescence
time result red and these can be run as
both end point for kinetic assays this
also has a powerful but very easy to use
scan it software for powerful and
intuitive analysis and also we've tried
to automate a lot of the experiments
using an online protocols library with
about 130 different pre-made protocols
let me show you what the data will
actually look like from this instrument
and how it might relate to actual
microscopy based instrument we're here
with the microlight reader we're
detecting all of the light from an
individual well a 96-well plate
you
so we see here on the left at several
dose-response curves of a five for nine
cells spheroids that were treated
different doses of cambogia cassie and
we're evaluating the signal from every
well of cells at different time points
and we can compare this to the same
plate the same 96 will play the
spheroids as analyzed by our high
content analysis system so with high
content analysis we have the images to
go along with every one of these data
points but it takes a bit longer to
acquire those images if we just want
quantitative information the Vario scan
plate reader can provide similar results
but in a much quicker analysis but we
can report similar toxicity profiles
with both instruments it really just
depends on what the desired output is of
this experiment is it just the
quantitative evaluation of viability or
is it that plus the localization of
individual cells within the images
and so that was three different ways we
can look at imaging and Ally they
spheroids or other three-dimensional
structures now let's move on and look at
the different assays and reagents
fluorescent dyes that we'll use to label
our spheroids to label our 3d structures
and also we'll pay attention to some
tricks that we've we found improve the
ability of some of our conventional dyes
and reagents to perform in these more
complicated models
so
we need to do a few things we need to
show that we can adapt existing reagents
to these 3d models and show how a wide
range of different methods can be used
here so we'll look at a few different
things first
at functional readouts and how we can
measure different things like viability
proliferation we can look at self health
as evidenced by things like ptosis
reactive oxygen species and also in this
category I include things like amino
oncology assays and will show several
examples of those and how we can
incorporate immuno oncology assays with
primary immune cells into these models
and third we'll look at how antibodies
are used here and including antibody
drug conjugates so
when we're looking at here the common
common model is to to grow spheroids out
of cancer cell lines and a common
readout here is how can we induce cell
death pathways into a common readout is
viability we're here we're showing the
in Beatriz in live dead cell imaging kit
applied to HeLa cells that were grown
into spheroids on our non clogs fear of
plates and treated with different doses
of the clothes amide so we see ourselves
going from green and healthy to red as
cell death is initiated and we see a
dose-dependent response here so this is
one common assay but as I mentioned
there are many other things that we
might be interested in measuring things
that are essentially measuring pre
lethal toxicity as well things like idle
con real health reactive oxygen species
pop ptosis or proliferation and cell
cycle so we look at examples of some of
these other assays now
so first let's look at a measurement of
caspase activity both a qualitative
measurement from an image of steroids
and the related quantitation on a
single-cell basis and so we can see here
a dose response of tell either again a 5
or 9 steroids created with increasing
concentrations of a drug the closest
amide and we see very little green
signal in our control but as we increase
the drug concentration we see individual
cells turning very brightly green
fluorescent and so we can do two things
based on just our white light image we
can plot the size of this spheroid and
show that increasing the drug
concentrations shrink this fear where
they they lead to death and shrinkage of
the spheroid but also we can correlate
that with killing as reported by our
sullivan caspase-3 7 probe and show a
quantitative increase in signal as our
other drug concentration is increased
this is some of the late measurement of
toxicity somewhat earlier measurement of
toxicity is provided by reactive oxygen
species detection and so we can use a
probe such as the in vitro giin cell
rocks deep red reagent will load our
entire spheroid or plate full of
spheroids with this reagent and as we
treat with different concentrations of a
drug mentos do we see an absence of red
signal in our control cells but we see
it a significant increase in red signal
reporting the presence of reactive
oxygen species as we increase the
concentration of our drug so we can see
this in the image but we can also
quantify this and illustrate the
increasing significantly increasing
presence of reactive oxygen species
we treat with this drug and so a tip
here to perform this experiment that
actually is common in 3d models is that
we may need longer incubation times to
achieve optimal signal and so here we
needed to increase the intubation time
for both the cell rocks
dye labeling to allow time for it to
penetrate through this this larger
structure we also needed a longer
occupation time or the drug for the same
reason to give it time to penetrate into
the thicker structure and so now this is
as you're translating your your
experiments to 3d this is something to
watch out for with a lot of different
assays and systems to increase the
incubation time and in some cases
increase the concentration of your your
reagent or your drug
let's move on and look at another
example this time at cell proliferation
and towards here we're using two
different probes one is in beat regions
cricket edu so edu is an analogue that's
incorporated into DNA of replicating
cells during S phase of the cell cycle
and we can detect that here in
individual cells colored green now ki-67
is a marker expressed in proliferating
cells as well in the nucleus of
proliferating cells here we've pseudo
color that red based on an antibody
based detection so we can see individual
cells within this top spheroid that are
either green or magenta recording a
positive signal or either or both of
those probes in the bottom see riod in
this panel we've treated with
hydroxyurea that inhibits proliferation
and we see an absence of green signal
from our edu and we see a minimization
of our ki-67 or I should say a reduction
in our ki-67 so when we actually
quantify this on a single-cell basis we
see in our two bar graphs that the alexa
fluor 48 ebu signal is eliminated by
treatment with the hydroxyurea we see an
absence of signal there with a ki-67 we
see a slight reduction and also the bar
graph on the right we can plot the
actual area of that steroid and show
that treatment with hydroxy urea leads
to a slight decrease in the cross
sectional area of that square root so
this is the way to multiplex two
different markers of proliferation as
well as to look at just the size of our
spheroid so I mentioned that we're not
just transitioning individual functional
assays like this but also multi cell
immune base TAS
so let's look at some different axes and
reagents for amino oncology and how we
translate these into three-dimensional
models so here we're looking at a car T
killing study of some colon cancer
steroids so we can see three different
spheroids that were formed and then
treated with car T cells designed to
target them at different effective
target ratios so on the Left we have no
T cells on the right we have lots of T
cells and in the middle we have out a
middle amount of T cells and so these
spheroids were fixed and firmed and
labeled with antibodies against
cytokeratin reporting our tumor cells
and tv3 Epsilon recording our car T
cells and of course hooks tour our
nuclear counter stain and we can see as
we increase the number of T cells we see
this clear degradation of the
three-dimensional structure of our
spheroid as the cells are as a spheroid
cells are killed so we're not actually
reporting killing by this assay but we
can by adding cytotoxicity markers such
as our sullivan caspase 7 reagent or
dyes like images dead green so let me
show you another example and how we can
instead of doing a fixed analysis like
this we can actually do a live analysis
of immune cell killing in 3d so let's
look at a natural killer cell antibody
dependent cellular cytotoxicity assay so
we'll grow spheroid in our knuckle on
Spira 96-well plate from SK BR 3 her2
positive breast cancer cells and we'll
label them here with nuke blue live
which labels the nuclei of live cells
with blue then we'll add cell event
caspase-3 7 reagent we see a few
individual spots of green reporting cell
death but there's not actually killing
happening here because we've not added
our natural killer cells so now let's
add
to this experiment in a separate well
with a separate spheroid will add some
primary human natural killer cells in
this case they were labeled with the
dice cell tracker deep bred so we can
identify them over time and what we see
here after four hours of incubation and
analysis with our cell insight dx7 laser
high content analysis system as we see
that our natural killer cells penetrate
to some extent into the spheroid and we
see individual spots of green reporting
killing of individual cells but we've
not added trust to Zermatt so we could
tell you this is antibody independent
killing look at antibody dependent
cytotoxicity let's add trastuzumab or
Herceptin to third well in this plate
and now we see not only more robust
penetration of these red NK cells into
the structure and more individual green
cells recording cell death but the
entire structure is degraded we're
actually seeing this entire tumor
spheroid following apart as the level of
toxicity so great love of killing by our
NK cells and so again this is a live
cell model where we're imaging live
after four hours we can do something
similar with live T cells or another
currently relevant model for cancer
therapeutics is with antibody drug
conjugates and so we can use the same
antibody say Herceptin and use a kit
called the featured in cyclic antibody
labeling kit that allows us to site
specifically label antibodies with
either a dye or a drug on a conservative
region of the antibody that FC domain so
essentially will will follow the
protocol of this kit to site
specifically attached either a dye or a
drug to this carbohydrate domain on our
body now when we put this on our tumor
spheroid with cells expressing her - we
actually created two versions of this
one with just a dye and one with a dye
and a tubulin destabilizing drug mono
methyl or statin II and so if we are to
to image these cells we see the
Herceptin labeled with just the dye and
the dye in this case is estado roto red
we apply this to a spheroid overnight in
this case 24 hours and we see that this
antibody has been taken up and actually
internalized to the lysosomes of at
every red cell in this spheroid we see a
couple of green spots reporting's and
spontaneous cell death but if we take
the same antibody and attach both the
dye the sto photo red and our mono
methyl or statin II now we see not only
red signal in individual cells from
internalization of this antibody drug
conjugate but we see bright green
circles reporting death of individual
cells as this toxin is internalized and
kills specifically individual cells so
several different models we can use
depending on what immuno oncology
modality we're we're interested in so
one one final thing to to look at as far
as general advice for the spheroid
models is when we're imaging these
larger structures we need to be aware of
photo bleaching this is the irreversible
destruction of the flora for as it's
exposed to excess light now we can
prevent this using anti fade reagent a
reagent that that fits this bill that
has existed for several years is in be
Trojan prolonged Dimond that provides
very valuable anti-fade protection in
thins
but for thicker specimens such as
spheroids or these cortical neuron
organoids we need something new called
the in Bucheon
prolong class prolong lass has a
refractive index of higher better match
to that of glass hourglass coverslips so
we see less light refraction gives us
better penetration of our light in the
direction allowing us to better
visualize cells on the interior of these
larger structures so this and a
prolonged glasses is very valuable for
this type of imaging a couple of other
general guidelines so first with respect
to labeling and labeling with
fluorescent reagents we need to optimize
our labeling conditions so we looked at
several examples here today where we
have optimized many common reagents for
use in 3d models if you're embarking on
a new protocol or transitioning your
current methods from 2d to 3d I'd look
at optimizing those as far as time and
concentration and seeing what works best
for your system and things we're looking
out for our heterogeneity and labeling
potentially that it could be a higher
signal on the exterior of our structures
as our dyes don't penetrate or we can
see increased backgrounds from these
thicker structures so things that are
valuable here are optical sectioning
using confocal microscopy as we saw with
the cx-7 laser instrument we're able to
visualize cells in a single plane of a
single optical slice two of our specimen
and we need to watch out for photo
toxicity especially if we're doing
analysis of live series where the
excessive exposure to light can be toxic
to those cells
so to summarize we looked at three
different categories of a three
dimensional analysis first why we would
want to transition to a three
dimensional model then we looked at the
instruments that allow us to perform
this mis type of analysis and then
several different examples of assays and
reagents that we find have great value
for studying biology in this more
relevant context so thank you for
joining us today and hand it over to
Christy
thank you Chris for your informative
presentation a quick reminder to our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
on the left side of your screen label to
ask a question type your question into
that box and click send our speaker will
answer as many questions as time permits
now any questions that we are not able
to address in our life presentation here
or any of those present submitted during
the on-demand period will be answered
via the email address you provided at
your time of registration okay so Chris
your first question is how can I reduce
photo bleaching or photo toxicity when
imaging thick samples
that's a great a great question and so
imaging these thick structures we do
have to worry about photo bleaching of
our fluorophores and also the toxicity
inducing ourselves by exposure to excess
light so for photo bleaching we can use
confocal imaging and limit our our
detection to a single plane of light we
can also use the the mounting media that
I showed a specifically prolonged glass
that will preserve our fixed samples and
prevent photo bleaching or destruction
of floor floors in those models
thank you thank you Chris guys thank you
guys our next question how can I
translate my current experiment into a
3d model
um yeah so good good question I think
that the points and towards the end
there was just general advice apply here
we're really we we may need to
experiment a little bit as you're
transitioning to a three-dimensional
model I'd highly recommend the knuckle
on sphere uh plates as a way to get
started making steroids with your
adherents and cell line of choice and I
think just allow some some room for
experimentation and and optimization
where on our website on thermo Fisher
comm there's information available on
how we've optimized several of the most
common assays for for 3d experiments and
so I think that's a good place to start
thanks Chris now let's go with this
question how did you make the round
steroids in this presentation
oh yeah so towards the beginning we
looked at a couple of different models
one where we're just using a standard
round bottom 96-well plate and we see
that when we seed adherent cells into
that type of dish then the untreated
round bottom dish sometimes will see
multiple spheroids form will see
multiple larger structures form but it's
not just one round spheroid and so we've
really found in our lab that using these
treated LEM cones fear of plates
essentially we just at aliquot ourselves
into every well and incubate overnight
and we have the nice round spheroids
they're consistent and and regular balls
of cells for for our models so
definitely recommend looking into those
thank you Chris now crystal lipstick we
have time for one more question
and I do see that we have more questions
in our queue so quick reminder to our
audience that those questions submitted
right now and any questions that do come
in during the on demand period these
will be answered via email okay Chris
our last question are there any tricks
to handling steroids
yeah thanks Christy um another good
question where all of the different
assays and reagents and and dyes that
we've discussed these are things that
we'll need to add to ourselves and in
many cases we'll need to wash ourselves
or in some cases fix and perm these are
all things that require media changes
and manipulating ourselves and so if
you're using a two-dimensional model of
adherent cells that's very easy because
your cells are stuck to the bottom of
your dish and so you can be fairly
vigorous with your washing and changing
of fluids with these spheroids
they're all just gently sitting in the
bottom of this this dish they're not
attached to anything so it need to be a
lot more gentle with our pipetting and
with our media changes or as you see
here on the final slide we actually
ended up with two spheroids in one well
because of a more aggressive washing and
so and just take your time
slow down on the pipetting and gently
aspirate your media and very gently
replace with you over reagent of
interest to make sure your your
spheroids
not only remain in well but they remain
as a nice intact ball of cells for your
your research so thanks for the question
yes and Chris thank you again for your
presentation on analyzing and
characterizing your 3d culture do you
have any final comments you like to
leave our audience with
yeah thanks Christy I think just to
refer everyone to the thermo Fisher comm
website where you can find a lot more
information on the protocols we've
developed for this type of assay I also
like to invite everyone to join us for
the next presentation in this series on
3d biology go thank you
thank you again Chris I'd also like to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
I'd like to thank our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on demand and Mavericks
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
you will now be redirected to register
for part four on 3d culture and analysis
hope to see you then
good bye